hey this is presh talwalkar
the green ring in annulus is the area
between two concentric circles
the line segment is tangent to the inner
circle and has a length of eight
what is the area of the ring in this
video i'm going to present five
different ways to solve this problem
even if you can get the correct answer
you might want to keep watching to the
end of the video where i give a brief
introduction to visual calculus
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
we'll first adjust the diagram in
several ways
we'll rotate the figure so the tangent
line is horizontal
next we'll draw the inner circle radius
with the length of b
vertically the radius makes a right
angle because the line is tangent
and it bisects the tangent line
so half of the tangent line will be a
length of four
i'll just draw one of the halves as a
equals four
finally draw the outer circle radius
with the length of c to be the
hypotenuse of the right triangle
the first way you can solve this problem
is to make convenient numbers
if the problem was on a multiple choice
test you can deduce there is a single
numerical answer that does not depend on
the dimensions of b and c
so you can pick convenient values for b
and c
we need a right triangle where one leg
is equal to four
we might as well use the three four five
right triangle which means b is equal to
three and c is equal to 5.
now we can solve the problem as follows
we can calculate the area of the outer
circle as pi times c squared
since c is equal to 5 this is equal to
25 pi
we then can calculate the area of the
inner circle
this will be pi times b squared
since b is equal to 3 this equals 9 pi
finally the area of the green ring is
the difference between the area of the
outer circle and the area of the inner
circle
so we subtract these two areas to get
the answer of 16 pi
if all you cared about was the correct
answer you could mark this on the exam
and move on
but there's a larger question
why does the answer not depend on the
dimensions of b and c
in the next few methods i'll present
some general proofs and also give you
some idea of why this is true
so first let's show that the answer
doesn't depend on the dimensions of the
circles
it only depends on the length a of the
tangent segment
we can proceed similarly but we're going
to use the pythagorean theorem
in a right triangle a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared which
means a squared is equal to c squared
minus b squared
now just like in the previous method we
calculate the area of the outer circle
this will be pi times c squared
we then calculate the area of the inner
circle this is pi times b squared
the area of the green ring will be the
difference between the area of the outer
circle and the area of the inner circle
so this will be pi times c squared minus
pi times v squared
and we know that c squared minus b
squared is equal to a squared by the
pythagorean theorem
therefore the answer only depends on the
quantity a
so when a is equal to 4 the answer again
is 16 pi but we've proven this generally
for any length so it always will be pi
times a squared
there's another special case that'll
allow you to solve this problem is to
take a limiting case
we'll let the inner circle
radius be equal to zero
so if we shrink the inner circle the
tangent chord will become the radius of
the outer circle
to show you what i mean by this i
created a demonstration on the website
desmos.com
it's a graphing calculator and a
calculator
and you can check it out i provided a
link in the video description
so i created a graphical version of this
problem i created some equations of
circles i shaded in the green ring and
we have a tangent chord whose dimension
i've set to be equal to a equals 4 is
half of the tangent length
the radius of the inner circle i started
out with the value of three
i then calculated the area in between
the two circles using calculus and using
the formula pi times a squared you'll
see they're equal to each other now you
can adjust these variables in desmos
so let's imagine shrinking the inner
circle radius
well obviously the outer circle radius
will have to adjust dynamically and you
can see that it keeps shrinking as well
when the inner circle radius goes all
the way down to zero we get that the
outer circle radius is equal to four and
that's exactly equal to the tangent
chord length of a equals four so you can
see that the tangent chord becomes the
radius of the outer circle and so we can
calculate the area you can see that the
area in these two formulas doesn't
change as you change the radius of the
inner circle it's only dependent on that
length a equals 4.
so what this means is we've calculated
that the error of the annulus is equal
to pi times a squared which equals 16 pi
and that's approximately 50.265
as shown in the desmos interactive
now just to follow up this decimal is
interactive you can also play around
with the length of the tangent chord
so you can see that if the tangent chord
increases you actually are going to
change the area in between the two
circles and if the tangent chord
decreases it's also going to change it
and you can see the two methods of
calculation give exactly the same
numerical answer
now for any particular value of the
tangent chord you're going to see that
the area of the green ring is unchanged
it only depends on the that value of the
parameter a
so it's an interesting interactive and
you can check it out and it'll give you
a deeper understanding for what's going
on
so now another way we can solve this
problem let's return to our diagram
we can use textbook geometry in the
intersecting chord theorem
so let's create some chords of the outer
circle
we'll extend the horizontal line
to be a chord of the outer circle and
we'll extend the vertical line to be a
chord of the outer circle
so we'll extend the vertical line this
will be a radius of the outer circle and
here will be
the difference between the radius of the
outer circle and the inner circle which
will be c minus b
so now let me remove some of the things
that we don't need we just have the
outer circle and we have two chords of
this outer circle intersecting
the second segment of the vertical chord
is equal to c plus b
so the two chords of the outer circle
intersect dividing each chord into two
segments the product of the two segments
of one chord equals the product for the
other chord of their two segments
so the horizontal chord is divided into
two segments four and four and the
vertical chord is divided into two
segments c plus b and c minus b
we multiply the segments of each chord
and set them equal to each other
this simplifies to be 16 is equal to c
squared minus b squared
that's the information we need and we
now return to our original diagram
we know the area of the ring is equal to
the area of the outer circle minus the
area of the inner circle and this will
be pi times the quantity c squared minus
b squared well we've calculated c
squared minus b squared is equal to 16
therefore we get the area of the ring is
equal to 16 pi
so this is just one more way that you
could solve this problem that doesn't
require in the pythagorean theorem
and you can actually just get this based
on the intersecting chord theorem
so now let me show you one more way you
could solve this problem
it's using a method known as visual
calculus or mamicon's theorem
in 1959 caltech student mamikan
natsukanyan devised a new approach to
solve the area of an annulus which led
to a new proof of the pythagorean
theorem
imagine rotating the triangle and
consider the area the tangent line
sweeps out
in particular
look at the area that side a sweeps out
it exactly sweeps out the area of the
annulus
now we can consider a discrete version
of this process
consider the area the tangent line
sweeps in 10 degree intervals
these are the shapes of the area swept
out in approximately 10 degrees
and these are just approximate shapes to
give you an idea of what's going on as a
sweeps around and rotates
so one way we can calc this area is
we're going to group all of these
tangent sweeps and we're going to
rearrange them so they have a common
center point
so we separate all of these tangent
sweeps and now we're going to rearrange
these so they're at a common center
point
and we end up with a new shape this has
exactly the same area as before
but what is this shape
well it should be reminiscent of a
familiar geometrical shape
this will be
something which has a length a radius of
a and it's going to be a circle with the
radius of a
now technically the circle is the
limiting shape for the tangent cluster
when the tangent sweeps are taken in
infinitesimally small degree intervals
but even in these 10 degree intervals
you could get an idea that these tangent
cluster would be a circle with the
radius exactly equal to the side length
a
so the tangent sweep has the same area
as the tangent cluster because all
you're doing is rearranging the tangent
sweeps into a new shape
so you could imagine a special case
where instead of sweeping out over the
annulus you actually have that length a
sweeping around a center point
so what shape would that make well that
would make a shape of the circle exactly
therefore we can calculate the area of
the tangent sweep of a of the annulus
instead of trying to calculate that we
could calculate it in terms of this
tangent cluster
well we know the area of a circle is
equal to pi times a squared
therefore that's also the area of the
annulus
this sort of thought process can be
generalized and formalized into
mannycon's theorem the area of a tangent
sweep is equal to the area of its
tangent cluster regardless of the shape
of the original curve the tangent line
sweeps
furthermore what we've just done is
we've come up with a new proof for the
pythagorean theorem just imagine that in
1959 someone comes up with a new proof
for a result that was known for
thousands of years
so why does this result in the
pythagorean theorem
well we calculated the area the annulus
is equal to pi times a squared
but we also know the area of the annulus
is the difference in the aries of the
circle which will be pi times the
quantity c squared minus b squared
so we can set these two formulas for the
area the annuals equal to each other
we can then cancel out the pi and
rearrange to get that c squared is
exactly equal to a squared plus b
squared so we have a new proof of a
thousands of year old theorem
so that's the answer to this problem
did you figure it out and which way of
solving the problem did you enjoy most
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions that you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description